Guys, right now it is time for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond to that topic.
So, since the new trailer for "Thor: Love and thunder"
came out this week -- I can't wait. It looks awesome.
I sent out the hashtag #RejectedSuperheroes.
And I asked you guys to share
some of your funniest ideas for a bad superhero name.
Within minutes, it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite rejected superheroes from you guys.
This first one here is from @mellotron42.
-Ooh. -Ooh.
-What is a mellotron, James? James, that's more like --
[ Imitating instrument ]
Do you have mellotron?
[ Mellotron melody playing ]
-Ooh. The Beatles.
-♪ Yeah, it's Beatle-y, it's Beatles ♪
♪ And it's John and it's Paul ♪
♪ And Ringo and, of course, it's George, too ♪
♪ Da, da-ba-da-da, whee ♪
Alright. That's a mellotron.
[ Applause ]
I like that sound.
All right, so, @mellotron42.
These are his bad superhero names.
He says..."Superman Bun."
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
-"You mind if I crash at your place for a week?"
-Wait. That's your super power?
-This one is from @Ghost-7.
-Ooh. -They say "The Wordler."
Oh. There you go, yeah. Interesting.
-"Spoil it for you!"
This one's from @GolobAdam. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @RyanBartholomee.
He says, "The Dad Joker." Oh, there you go, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That should be a character. I like that one.
Is there any good dad jokes? Have you heard any?
-Lately? -Yeah. Or old ones?
You got any good ones? -Oh, my God.
I've got so many, I can't even remember one.
-I know. I'm trying to think of a good dad joke that I heard.
No, I told that already on the show.
-Was it dirty? -No.
-Was it filthy? -No!
Uh...
-Come on! One.
-I'm on a seafood diet.
-What's that?
-Fish, you know, salmon.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
Turn it -- Little twist. Turning it on its head.
Yeah, exactly.
-I expected you to say, "I see food, I eat it."
-This is from @BrigGreene. He says...
"The 'MansCaped Crusader.'"
Oh, interesting. -Oh, hey.
-Caped -- Wow.
This one's from @ChefDisney.
-Ooh! -That's a good name.
You can get that? -Chef Disney?
-I'm assuming, right? -You think he works at Disney?
-I don't.
-Do you think he's a chef?
-I don't think -- Chef Disney is such a --
I mean, you'd think that'd be taken up.
-Yeah. -By the chef from Disney.
-Yeah.
-Maybe she is the chef at Disney.
I have no idea. But I don't think so.
-But there's no number after it?
-No, you'd think it'd be -- What, like --
-Like @ChefDisney500... -Yeah, no.
The only -- Like, this is the original Chef Disney.
-Wow. -Wow.
-Ooh la la!
-[French accent] I'm making -- Be our guest. I know.
Making Mickey Mouse pancakes for over 50 years!
-Mwah!
-@ChefDisney. She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like, give him time. He's on his way.
He'll fight crime.
This one's from @JeremyIzzy1. He says...
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
Jeremy Izzy had to put a "1" after his name.
Because there was already one before Jeremy Izzy.
-No Chef Disney, man. -No. Chef Disney nailed it.
-I might go do, like, @ChefDisney2.
-You'd probably get a lot of followers.
-Yeah, I'll pretend I'm Chef Disney.
They won't know the difference.
-I don't think this person is a chef at Disney.
-Really? -I don't think you'd --
-You think Disney would go, "Don't."
-Yeah, I think Disney would say no
and I think you probably also, as the chef from Disney,
you would probably be like,
"You know, I got enough going on."
-"Yeah. I'm busy." -"I don't wanna bring my work --
Yeah, I don't want to bring my work to my...
-"I cook for about a million people a day. It's too much."
-"Yeah, I want to go on Twitter and just, like, say
what I don't like about something or..."
-Complain about Goofy.
-Yeah.
'Cause if you're Chef Disney, it'll get traced back to you.
-You'll get busted. They'll go,
"Hey, did you say this about Goofy?"
"Yeah."
-Yeah. -"You're fired."
-Our last one here is from @MylaCardero.
She says "Jersey Thor."
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our "Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.